[MUSIC]
Welcome, my name is Jessica Talbert and
I'm a second year MBA at
Stanford Graduate School of Business.
And I'm here today with Kirsten Moss,
Assistant Dean and
Director of Admissions and Financial Aid.
>> Hi, Jessica.
Thanks for the introduction.
As admissions officers, we spend much of
our time traveling around the world and
meeting with candidates to share
information about Stanford.
And whether or not it could be a good
fit for what they're looking for
in their graduate education experience.
But today we want to do
something different.
Instead of talking about Stanford,
we want to talk about you and how you if
you're interested in applying can put
your best foot forward in the process.
>> What are some of the most common myths
about the Stanford application process?
>> I think the myth that I hear
most frequently is that members of
the Admissions Committee at Stanford
have some magic checklist that each
applicant must fulfill in order
to be admitted to our program.
I've heard things like I have to
have a GMAT score over a 700, or
I need to work in a particular
industry to be admitted, or
even come from a particular type
of educational institution.
And really nothing could
be farther from the truth.
If you think about the last few
classes that we've admitted,
we have students from over
60 different countries.
We have students from 160 different
educational institutions.
And we have students coming from I think
on average over 300 different work
environments before they come,
different companies.
And there's only 400 students in a class.
So you can see in reality, we're admitting
humans for what they've done, and
who they are.
We're not admitting people just because
they went to a certain institution, or
worked in a certain industry.
In fact, I was just, I think it
was a few weekends ago, we were at
Admitted Students Weekend, which I
know you've been to, Admit Weekend.
And there were two
students I was talking to.
And one of them said that, both of them
said they almost didn't apply to Stanford.
I came this close to not applying,
I'm like, why?
One said, he was in a chatroom,
and somebody told him that,
Stanford would never admit you because
of the university that you went to, and
he went to a state school in the Midwest.
And then another student said
the same thing that happen to her.
And one of our peers from work had told
her, they are talking about where they
wanted to apply that with her GPA and
test score should never get into Stanford.
So luckily for us, both of these students
decided that for themselves whether or
not they should apply and
are now going to be entering this fall, so
we're really excited about that.
>> How do you decide then whether or not
you have a shot at getting into Stanford?
>> That's a great question, that's
probably the million dollar question.
And I'm hoping all what we discussed today
will give applicants insight into whether
or not they have a shot.
But I think if I had to go to the essence
like what is absolutely most important
than making that decision.
We're trying to answer two questions
on the Admissions Committee.
The first is, is this particular applicant
going to be engaged academically when
they come to our program?
And the second is, what kind of impact
will they have after they graduate?
And if you think, well, we care about
their educational engagement because we're
a higher education institution,
we want our classroom to be vibrant.
You probably know as a student, the more
interested folks are when they're in there
learning and curious the better and
richer that experience will be.
Then on the flip side, we do care and
believe in our tagline.
We want to know when we're selecting these
students that they have the potential to
change lives, change organizations,
and change the world.
Jessica, I'm curious about how you
decided whether to apply to Stanford?
>> For me, it was about thinking
am I ready to take the next
leap in my career and not the just step?
I've spent about five years in retail and
tech, and kind of formulated an idea of
the kind of impact I wanted
to have on those industries.
But I wasn't exactly sure what the best
step forward was in order to be
successful.
I think knowing that I was ready to make
that impact is what helped me decide to
apply.
>> It's great, how did you
approach the application process?
>> The application process?
>> [LAUGH]
>> I think I thought about it in two ways
mainly.
The first one was really
about introspection.
Really understanding who I was,
what I wanted to get out of the world and
what kind of impact I wanted.
And it's easier said than done.
For me, it took the form of journaling
every morning and then kind of
looking back after a couple of months and
seeing what common themes there were.
What was important to me
on a day to day basis?
And I think once I crystallized around
that I had a really good idea of like,
what I really wanted to get out of it and
who I was.
The second part was about
information gathering.
Making sure that what I wanted to get out
of it was actually where business school
is going to be like and not just what
I thought it was going to be like.
And that was coming through
Stanford's resources,
going to town halls that your
office would go to around the US.
And really talking to alumni and
current students.
Can we talk about how you
evaluate whether someone will
engage academically at Stanford?
>> We're looking for students who
are curious, who are willing to
share their perspectives both inside and
outside of the classroom.
And perhaps most importantly
we're looking for
students who want to seek new ideas,
new perspectives, almost insights or
truth, and
to do that in a collaborative way.
When you leave GSB as a leader,
you're going to go out and
have some tough problems to solve, but
you're not going to do it by yourself.
You're not going to do it
in your own head somewhere.
So really having someone who'd going to be
leveraging the thoughts of others to come
up with the best possible
solution is important.
To assess these behaviors, we look at
multiple places in the application.
The most obvious would be the transcript.
And for me, I usually read,
I'll take a day, Tuesdays and
Thursdays during application season,
I get to read from home.
My favorite thing to do, and
every time my [LAUGH] I get that really
long with the applicants and your stories.
But when I open a file, one of first thing
I do is I go to the transcript because I
tell so much about someone.
What are the kind of courses you took,
what are you most interested in studying.
Are you someone who went broad, I like to
see how different the discipline connect
with each other,
ot maybe someone who were very deep.
So that's step one, and
I do get information about how curious
someone is and how the rigor and
course choices impacted them.
But perhaps more importantly than
the transcript is looking for
evidence of this curiosity and
other things that people have done.
So perhaps you were at work and
there's a tough problems to solve and
you worked with others to figure it out.
Or perhaps you did research at your
university beyond your classes.
One of my most recent favorite stories
was from someone we admit in this class,
and then-
>> It wasn't like.
>> No it wasn't yours, sorry,
Jessica, it could have been though.
And it was an individual, I think he was
in business development in a tech company.
It was a growing tech company, and
he joined when the company
was only about 50 people.
And he said one of the things he loved
best when he joined was that wherever
he was there was laughter in the hallways.
And he thought that was a sign of
people being optimistic, innovative.
And then as time went on and
they were doubling and
tripling in size the laughter went away.
And he remembered going to
an all hands meeting and
asked the senior management,
this is a concern, what can I do?
And came up with the idea
to do a pulse survey.
The only problem with to
check in with the culture.
The only problem was he said he had
no idea how to do an HR survey,
what cultural engagement was, how to build
it, how to write questions, all of that.
But you watch him go through a path of
just curiosity of meeting with experts,
both in the company and
outside of the company.
Researching material to figure out, yeah,
what are some good benchmark surveys,
how do we develop questions that'll work?
Luckily they had some PhD students in this
company who were doing business analytics
that I could get help from.
But the point is, that's a great
story about using your curiosity and
your drive to find truth about
this company to come up with.
They essentially came up with a great
answer about what they could be doing
differently as they move forward, so.
Hopefully, that helps give you
a sense of what I'm looking for and
how I'm looking for it.
>> Many students, myself included,
are worried about their test scores.
What advice do you have there?
>> This is probably the most
frequently asked question that I get is
what about my GMAT score,
what about my GRE?
And the reality is we accept students
with a wide range of test scores, and is
just one data point and I truly mean that.
Well, we look at the tests and they are
important to ensure that you're going to
be able to thrive quantitatively and
verbally in the program.
So my best advice is we look at it,
you should take spend some time preparing.
What I hope for every applicant is
when they submit that score and
I know it's stressful,
that you feel it's at least a decent
reflection of what your capabilities are.
So that's where the preparation comes in.
That being said, though, I know for many
students test taking is not their forte.
So again, if there's a score, honestly,
in an application where it's far from
maybe what our median might be and
we do admit people in the 500s,
the 600s, and the 700s.
But if I see this may not be the strongest
point of their application, that's when
I'm diving in into the transcript and
seeing again, how do they learn?
Maybe tests just aren't their thing.
>> So I'd like to ask you about GPA.
Stanford says that there's no minimum GPA.
But can you get in with a low GPA?
I'd also like to know how you
evaluate GPAs outside of the US?
>> Both of those questions come up
from applicants often, as well.
Again, the GPA is just one indicator,
but this one is about a four-year period
of time, often a three or
four-year period of time.
So we do look at that.
For us, if you think about the GPA,
we know that it's going to vary by
institution, the level of the GPA,
also even by major.
Sometimes I find that highly rigorous
quantitative majors or sometimes
more science oriented, on average,
students' GPA will be lower there.
So that's something we're
taking into consideration.
In addition,
if you think about international schools,
we don't convert their
GPAs into US conversions.
We actually look at the country and
try to be familiar with what's their
educational system and recognize that
oftentimes international GPAs are less
inflated than US GPAs may be.
So all of that is for
you to realize that we're trying to do our
best to understand what they looks
like in your particular context.
That being said,
if you look at your transcript and
take it look at it with fresh
eyes on an applicant, and
you see a point in time, a semester,
quarter or whatever it was where
you don't think it reflects your true
capabilities, tell us about that.
We have an additional information section.
It could've been health.
It could've been a personal situation.
We're looking for reasons to admit you,
not for reasons to deny.
So any contexts that you can
give us to help understand
what your trajectory has
been will be really helpful.
That's great.
I like the framing of that too.
We're looking for
reasons to admit us, not to deny us.
>> Exactly.
>> And no applicant is going to be
outstanding in every dimension.
So you put your best foot forward and
know that those strengths
are the important things.
>> Let's discuss letters of reference.
What advice do you have for
choosing recommenders?
>> I don't know if applicants really
appreciate how important the letters of
reference are.
It's really the one opportunity that we
get to see you through someone else's
eyes objectively.
What did you do and how did you do it?
So, for me, put a lot of
emphasis on making a selection.
I can give you some tips
on how to think about it.
At Stanford, we request two and one we
ask for a current direct supervisor or
the best alternative if that is
impossible or inappropriate.
And then for the second recommendation,
we also ask for
someone who supervised your work.
But it could be for
a non-profit, it could be extracurricular
or from the same organization.
Now, when you think about selecting them,
we really just as I've asked applicants in
their essays to tell us about the impact
that they've had, because this past
behavior will predict future behavior,
that's the echo that we
want to see in the reference.
So find someone who knows what you've
done, really been in the trenches and
can see your work and describe not just
what happened but how you did it, and
how the way you did it might
have been different from others.
So that means don't worry
about the title of a person,
don't try to get the highest title.
Also, I hear a lot of students asking or
applicants asking,
should I try to find someone who went
to Stanford because that's important?
No, it's not,
it's actually what the recommender can
tell us about you that is most important.
The second thing is after them
understanding what you've done is
enthusiasm.
This is [LAUGH] hard for someone who
reads thousands of recommendations.
This one's a hard one to
wrap your hands around.
But I know the best recommendations that I
read are written from both a headspace and
a heart space.
So try to think about who you've
established a relationship with,
someone who really
enthusiasm a great work,
but has a connection with you and
will be able to speak to that.
And that's how recommendations
become most memorable.
And then lastly, I think applicants
should think about the process.
Don't ask for recommendation in an email.
It's going to take this person
a significant amount of time.
On average,
our references are about two pages.
I'm guessing people has to spend at least
an hour or two to do a good job on them.
What is most disappointing to me, when I'm
really looking to find reasons to admit,
is I'll get to the end of an application,
I'll be on the second recommendation and
I'll see someone everything has been so
positive.
And they'll write a positive
recommendation, but
maybe only two paragraphs, and
just say, they're phenomenal.
They're the best ever.
They've done a great job.
But I won't have any of that
data to help me make a decision.
And it just means that this particular
applicant doesn't have as much data,
I guess, is the best word,
but landscape for
me to really understand what they've
done and how they've done it.
So take it seriously.
Make an appointment,
even if it's a 15 minute chat.
But ask the question courageously and
say, will you write it?
Explain why, where you're going,
what schools.
And then say, do you have time to
invest to do a good job on this?
And if someone says they're really busy,
that a good indication that maybe
you should go to your second choice.
because it can make a difference
in the end of how much they're
willing to spend time to
help you in this process.
>> And then for the recommenders,
are there any resources for them or
how do they know how to
write then to get the best?
>> That's a great question.
We try to give, and many recommenders
have written more than one before, but
we try to give them clear advice and
tips when they're invited onto
our portal on the website.
The questions will ask,
how has this person differentiated
themselves from others that
they've seen doing similar roles?
And what have they done and accomplished?
So they'll get that.
And I think it comes down to that
they're willing to take the time to
really support you.
There's no magic there, but
they do have to make that investment and
be close enough to you to be able to write
thoughtfully about what you've done.
>> Yeah, many reapplicants worry that
they are disadvantaged to first time
applicants.
Is that true?
And do you have any advice for
people are trying to reapply?
>> We really read them fresh, so my best
advice is the person who is evaluating
your application likely
has never seen it before.
So there's no reason to
explain what's different or
what changed or
maybe why you think you didn't get in.
Some people will try to tell us that.
Just start fresh and
look at what you've already submitted.
You don't have to change everything.
But think is there something at this
moment in time that could be more
compelling, perhaps, that the last?
Or some way you want to change it to
be more representative of where I am at
this moment.
But please do,
if you're committed to Stanford, reapply,
because there's a lot of students
that we admit from that category.
>> Some of my favorite
classmates are reapplicants, so-
>> They told you?
[LAUGH]
>> So I'm really
glad-
>> That's great.
>> That they're here.
>> That's awesome.
>> If an applicant does get an interview,
how would you recommend they prepare for
that interview?
>> Well, first of all, if an applicant
gets an interview, congratulations.
That's a really good sign.
>> Yeah, that's awesome.
>> We usually interview about two
candidates for every spot that we have.
So number one,
the word prepare is a really good one.
If you've made it this far and
worked this hard I treat this is as
an important part of the process.
Unlike some other schools,
we use our alumni for interviewers and
they are all around the globe.
We try to match it with people from your
country, maybe perhaps an industry that
you're in, if possible currently in,
so they really understand you.
And it's in two parts.
The first half an hour
is primarily evaluative.
And then the last 15 minutes,
it's a chance for
you to meet someone from the community.
So come prepared with
the mindset to do both.
In the first part,
it's a behavioral based interview.
So the stories that we were talking
about before, come ready to tell them.
We're going to want to know
about what you're most proud of.
What was the context?
What was the challenge?
What did you do?
How did you do it?
And then what was the impact?
So expect some probing
around those stories.
And then on the second part,
it's fun, our community's so tight.
[LAUGH] I enjoyed my interview
a lot actually, I had a great time.
>> And did you enjoy the interviewer?
>> I did and
he was pretty expert, actually.
He was really good and
really drawing stories out of me,
rather than like intense questions.
By the end of it, I felt that there were
somebody that I'd really gotten to know
and somebody who is a part of
a community I was excited to be part of.
So the interview is actually really great
for me and getting excited for school.
>> And that's a wonderful way
to help with the second tip.
That last part of the interview,
it's a gift.
It's a chance to develop a relationship.
Come prepared with some questions that you
want to know about Stanford, obviously.
But see it as just one entry step to
being part of a bigger community.
>> So there is a lot of
information out there for
people applying to business school.
I know I went through a lot of it.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Some of it helpful, some of it not.
What are the best resources for
applying to Stanford?
>> I think you make a good point, there is
a lot of misinformation out there as well.
We really believe the best information,
start with what we put
up there on the website.
What's nice about it now is there's lots
of conversations with students out there,
so you can learn what it's
actually like from the students.
I think that's more interesting
than hearing it from admissions.
[LAUGH]
>> Yes.
>> As well as there's profile information,
tips about the application, start there.
But one of the most
important things you can do
is also go to an information session.
We do about a hundred of
them around the globe.
And the reason for
that is you'll get a panel,
usually three to five recent graduates.
And they can tell you, we believe that
Stanford can be transformational for
you both in what you learn,
but also how you develop.
So you can actually listen
to how this experience has
impacted people in their own lives.
Both from how they went through as well as
what they're doing now when they graduate.
I think that's one of the best
ways you can truly be inspired but
also get your questions answered.
And if we're not coming to your hometown,
then go to the Web.
We have a virtual one too,
where you can hear students talking and
recent alumni about their experiences.
>> Any other advice?
>> Before I give you my last words of
wisdom or my last piece of advice.
We've been spending the last
half an hour talking about
how the admissions committee
evaluates candidates.
But I would really like to
put you on the spot and
say you started two years ago,
you're about to graduate.
>> Yes.
>> Just a few weeks?
I'm curious what surprised you most
about joining this community of students
at the GSB?
>> This has just been such
an amazing two years.
Difficult but amazing, and
I think a couple things surprised me.
The first one is that I knew that
I was going to come here and
find really intelligent classmates,
really accomplished classmates.
People who were going to make
me feel like I didn't do a lot.
>> [LAUGH].
>> But I don't think I could have fathomed
just the breadth of experience and
passions that these people would have.
And how important that was going to
be to me in my experience here.
I could have a good idea of like what
the academics were going to look like, but
not really the people I was going to meet.
And I've met some of the most
amazing people in the world here.
And for that, I'll be really grateful.
The second thing that I think was really
surprising to me is that I expected to
become a better business person here.
But I didn't expect to become a better
person and I really do think that I have.
I think a lot of that I owe to the breadth
of experience from my classmates and
the time I've spent with them.
>> What do you mean a better person?
>> A better person.
>> That's well said.
>> I think it's about having the tools
to be a little bit more introspective.
To examine the way that I go through the
world, my own biases and challenge them.
And then really having the toolkit to do
that consistently and throughout my life.
So that I know when I leave this place,
I will be able to look back on
this experiences and drawn them.
And maybe do a better job than
would have before business school.
>> That's great thank you,
I appreciate that.
Here is my closing advice, this is for
all you applicants out there.
I think what's most important
to me is to tell you do not
underestimate your own potential.
There's no perfect applicant.
There's no checklist that we're looking
at of attributes that we require.
Decide for yourself whether
you're worth the investment
to go through the application process.
What I know from talking to many,
many applicants in the past.
That you spending the time to know
what's most important to you,
what you value, what your aspirations are.
And then what you've really done and
accomplishments you've had,
those are going to be critical to you at
this point in time, no matter what you do.
We're genuinely excited
to learn about you,
to learn about how you've actually
had impact on your teams,
your organizations and
your communities and what you care about.
So if you have a story to tell us,
you know that we're here and
generally ready to and excited to read it.
So thanks so much, Jessica,
for taking the time.
>> And thank you so much for
this, Kirsten, really.
This was really helpful.
[MUSIC]